hello everybody welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and a few weeks ago i'm recording this
in april 2021
uh we had not one but two different
reports of completely independent
anomalies in particle physics that is to
say
apparent disagreements between the
theoretical predictions
based on the standard model of particle
physics which is very well established
and new experimental results one of the
results came from the large hadron
collider outside geneva switzerland
the other from fermilab outside chicago
illinois they both involve
muons little particles that are heavier
cousins of the electrons but they're
otherwise
not immediately connected to each other
we don't yet know
whether these anomalies are real in some
sense i mean the anomalies are real
they're there
but we don't know where they actually
represent new physics or we just made a
mistake either experimentally or
theoretically
so lots of people have asked for my
opinion about these things so that's
what this podcast is gonna do
but because i am who i am uh i'm not
going to focus
mostly on what it means for the future
of particle physics because
we don't know what it means for the
future of particle physics i mean number
one
we don't know if it's real like we just
said we don't know if it's going to
stick around either one
and number two the data that we're
getting the information that we're
measuring
is kind of meager right you're measuring
two different numbers
in two different ways and that's not
quite enough to be very explicit about
what model might explain it the problem
with this kind of thing is
there's many models that could possibly
explain this so you can't instantly say
ah
you've detected this therefore
supersymmetry or therefore grand
unification or anything like that
but we can be prepared for hopefully
getting more data and hopefully
understanding better the theoretical
models that can be constructed
if we think about exactly what's going
on so that's what i want to talk about a
little bit about the standard model in
general
a little bit about the specific ways in
which new physics can
enter these measurements a little bit
about what it means
to be skeptical about statistical
confidence all of that stuff
uh one very quick thing is that the
standard model
has not been upended the laws of physics
has not have not been up ended
this is something that you might get the
impression of from certain newspaper
headlines i'm not going to name any
names
but it's not a complete rethink of the
basic laws of physics it's a little bit
extra
it could you know if you want to get
excited about it that's okay
it could lead to an entirely new era of
physics beyond the standard model
but it doesn't replace the standard
model the standard model is still there
in a way that i will very much
try to explain hopefully it all makes
sense um
we've been looking for experiments that
do not fit the standard model
for a very very long time for my entire
career in physics we have dark matter
that exists we have dark energy that
exists
but nothing really in particle physics
experiments here on earth
that have been directly contradicting
the standard model so if
true it's big even if we can't quite say
where it's going to lead so let's go
[Music]
so very quickly let's go over what the
claimed anomalies
are so i'm not going to dig into all the
details quite yet but get things on the
table and then we'll be able to
understand what's going on a little bit
more carefully okay
so i gotta tell you because maybe you
don't know there's something out there
called the standard model of particle
physics right
there's a bunch of particles and forces
that have done an extremely good job
in explaining us you me the stuff we're
made of
the table in front of you the signals
that are passing through the internet
etc to give you this podcast all of that
is incredibly well
accounted for in what we call the
standard model of particle physics even
you know
the sun the moon and the stars they
count to that's all the standard model
of particle physics
and the standard model very quickly
there's two kinds of
particles in fact there's two kinds of
fields because it's really quantum field
theory as we'll briefly discuss
but that's okay perfectly legit to talk
about it in terms of particles
the two kinds of particles are matter
particles what we call
fermions these are particles that make
up matter they take up space
you cannot pile an arbitrary number of
fermions on top of each other
the other kind are the bosons bosons are
the force-carrying particles right
photons gluons gravitons things like
that
but it's the matter particles we're
going to be dealing with today
and they in the standard model come in
two varieties and there's sort of a
parallelism
which is interesting all by itself
there's a lot of sneaky symmetries and
patterns in the standard model that are
not perfectly well
understood so in the standard model a
very boring name for very important
theory
there are six kinds of quarks and there
are six kinds of leptons so there's a
parallelism right there
and the difference between a quark and a
lepton is quarks
feel the strong nuclear force they
interact directly with the particles
called
gluons so quarks you don't see you never
see
a quark by itself in the wild they're
confined the strong nuclear force is so
strong that quarks are just grouped
together
usually in either triplets of three
kinds of quarks
that's what would be a proton for
example is two up quarks and a down
quark
a neutron is two down quarks and an up
quark
the six kinds of quarks are up down
charm strange
top and bottom okay that's more or less
not exactly that's more or less an
increasing mass
so the heavier ones like the top which
is the heaviest and the bottom
they just decay away very quickly it's
the up and down quarks
that make up the protons and neutrons
and you and me
and the other kind of particles that we
regularly find with quarks in them
are mesons these are quark antiquark
pairs so you might think well if i had a
quark and an antiquark wouldn't they
annihilate
yes except that i could have an up quark
for example and a down
antiquark so two particles a particle in
an anti-particle will annihilate if
they're the same kind of particle
but if it's one particle of one kind and
an anti-particle of a different kind
they don't annihilate
as a matter of fact mesons do eventually
annihilate one way or the other but they
can stick around for a relatively long
time so
pions chaons things like that these are
combinations of one quark and one
antiquark
so that's how we get quarks there's six
kinds of quarks they come in either
groups of
three quarks or groups of one quark and
an antiquark
there's also six leptons the leptons are
the particles that
don't feel the strong nuclear force on
average
the leptons are a little bit lighter
than the quarks sometimes a lot lighter
so the leptons are the electron which we
know very well that's very important for
atoms molecules stuff like that and then
there are two heavier cousins of the
electron
the muon which we'll be talking a lot
about today is about 200 times heavier
than the electron
and then there's the tau particle which
is even heavier than that
and again heavier particles tend to
decay away so you don't see a lot of
muons or tau particles lying around in
the everyday world they would decay
into electrons the reason by the way
that heavier particles tend to decay
into lighter ones is
roughly speaking because entropy likes
to increase
when you decay when you're let's say a
muon you don't
just decay into an electron you also
spit off
neutrinos those are the other kinds of
leptons there's an electron neutrino a
muon neutrino and a tau
neutrino so there's three charged
leptons three neutrinos those are the
six
leptons we have when a muon decays it
spits out an electron
but then also a mu a neutrino and an
anti-neutrino
so it turns into three different
particles and that
little bit increases the entropy of the
universe going from just one particle
into three particles
you can take the three particles and in
principle
go backwards right if you very very
carefully
line up a neutrino an anti-neutrino and
an electron and shoot them at each other
there will be a chance that they convert
into a muon
but it's a very very small chance the
history of the universe is mostly
heavier particles decaying into lighter
ones
increasing the entropy of the universe
okay so that's the
set of ingredients we have to work with
six quarks up down
charms range top bottom six leptons
electron muon tau
and there are three neutrinos and the
standard model
is the name we give to the set of rules
that are obeyed
by all these fermions the quarks and the
leptons and also all the bosons the
force carrying particles that hold them
together
and so when i say predicts the
interactions what i mean is there's a
very very precise and quantitative
recipe
for answering questions like what is the
rate at which a muon or a tau decays
into an electron when you make a meson
out of a quark in an antiquark and it
eventually decays how
quickly does that happen if i shoot an
electron and a positron the
anti-electron at each other
what do they convert into and what is
the probability that they convert into
all these different things okay
the standard model makes highly precise
quantitative predictions for all that
kind of stuff
all the interactions basically that go
into making up you and me
now usually inside you and me particles
are not being created or destroyed
but electrons are interacting with
protons
in the atomic nucleus to make atoms
that's also predicted very very well
by the standard model of particle
physics so
the standard model was put together
roughly in the 60s and 70s
it was put together you know there's
enough sort of constraints on what could
possibly be going on
that by the mid 70s we had a very good
idea of what this list of particles
would be
what the list of quarks and the list of
leptons would be even though we hadn't
discovered all of them yet it was
after the standard model was put
together that we discovered
the bosons that carry the weak nuclear
force
the w and z bosons we directly detected
at least evidence for
the gluons that make up the strong
nuclear force as well as things like the
heavier neutrinos and the top quark etc
not to mention of course the higgs boson
that lurks in the background of all this
these were all
particles that were predicted to be part
of the standard model
and only discovered later so the last
few decades of particle physics have
largely been
a story of discovering particles that
are in the standard model that we
already had predicted
and testing their properties and finding
that those properties
are what is predicted by the standard
model of particle physics so it's a
bittersweet situation to find yourself
in
as a particle physicist on the one hand
theoretically
you've constructed this wonderful theory
right you know the the
the incredible genius of particle
physicists
over the decades from you know people
like dirac
and fermi inventing quantum field theory
to people like feynman and schwinger and
tomonaga
understanding how quantum field theory
works to people like
you know higgs and brow and anglair
understanding spontaneous symmetry
breaking nambu
and goldstone and weinberg and salam
understanding the electro weak theory
and gross and pulitzer and wilczek and
galman putting the pieces together to
make the strong nuclear forces and a
tuft showing that it was all
renormalizable i mean
many many contributions from many many
nobel prize-winning
people that made up the standard model
of particle physics not to mention
the equal number of nobel prize-winning
efforts by the experimentalists
discovering
evidence for quarks the existence of the
heavier quarks the higgs boson all this
stuff
okay so we're very happy with our
ability to predict things in the
standard model of particle physics
but the flip side of that that's the
sweet part the bitter part is
it's hard to make progress in physics
when your theory works too well
when your theory fits all of the data
but
this is the thing you gotta understand
nobody thinks
that the standard model of particle
physics is the final theory of
everything
we're a hundred percent not a hundred
never 100 that's an exaggeration you got
carried away there a little bit sorry
about that
we are quite confident let's put it that
way
that there is physics beyond the
standard model in a very trivial sense
there is gravity
right gravity is not included in the
standard model of particle physics
those of you that have heard me talk
about the core theory that's a coinage
due to frank wilcheck uh
which does include gravity but only in
weak gravitational fields
so we can include quantum gravity when
you're talking about the planets
orbiting the sun
but we don't have a quantum theory of
gravity that explains black holes or the
big bang and stuff like that so that's
obviously
a need for new physics plus there's dark
matter
right there's some particle out there
most of the mass of the universe
and there's also questions like why is
there more matter than anti-matter
in the universe these are all questions
which are presumably
addressable but only if you go beyond
the standard model of particle physics
so
it's a frustrating situation to be in
when your theory is so good but you know
it's not right
what can you do right you can make
guesses basically
everything from super symmetry in the
1970s
to very new ideas about hidden sectors
and dark photons and stuff like that
these are
various kinds of guesses about what
might lie beyond the standard model
guessing is easy figuring out which
guess is correct is hard
that's why we need experimental input
that's what's going to eventually help
us whittle down the guesses
to which ones are correct if any of them
or inspire completely new guesses
if you're a business owner you might be
making running your business harder on
yourself than necessary
don't let quick books and spreadsheets
slow you down anymore
it's time to upgrade to netsuite
netsuite by oracle
is the world's number one cloud business
system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control over your financials
hr inventory e-commerce and more
everything you need all in one place
instantaneously
stop paying for multiple systems that
don't give you the information you need
when you need it and ditch the
spreadsheets and all the old software
you've outgrown
whether you're doing a million or
hundreds of millions in revenue you can
save time
and money with netsuite join the over 24
000 companies
using netsuite right now and you can let
netsuite show you
how they'll benefit your business with a
free product
tour by going to netsuite.com mindscape
schedule that free product tour right
now at n-e-t-s-u-i-t-e
dot com slash mindscape that's
netsuite.com
mindscape anyway i'm supposed to be
giving you what the anomalies were i got
carried away
there's so much here to say when i was
thinking about this solo podcast uh i
was just trying to figure out the order
in which to say things and there's many
different possible orders anyway
here are the two pieces of news we got
to to be clear
these are both reaffirmations of
existing anomalies we've already known
about
but anomalies and particle physics are a
dime a dozen there's many many times
when people will say oh here's an
experimental result
which does not quite agree with the
predictions of the standard model
and then a few years go by you collect
more data and it evaporates it goes away
this has happened
so often that particle physicists have
become a little bit
jaded by the whole prospect like oh yeah
another anomaly so these days
when there's an anomaly when there's a
mismatch between the theory
and the prediction in standard model
physics we wait
we wait for more data to come in for a
different experiment to look at the
whole process to ask ourselves are we
really on to something
so what's what is important here is not
a brand new anomaly
these are anomalies that we have checked
and they still
seem to be there okay so that's actually
a higher level of excitement
than if you have a brand new anomaly one
of the anomalies the one that came from
the
lhc the large hadron collider outside
geneva
it has to do with b mesons b
stands for bottom which means that a b
meson contains a bottom quark
and some other antiquark it could be an
up antiquark down antiquark etc you know
there's some
lighter antiquark or vice versa there
are bemezons that have
a bottom antiquark and a lighter quark b
mesons and b
anti-b anti-b mesons b anti-mesons i
don't even know what the right way to
say it is
a collection of particles that contain a
bottom quark okay
why do we have any special love for
particles for mesons that contain bottom
quarks
well bottom quarks are pretty heavy
they're not as heavy as top quarks top
quarks are even heavier
but we'll see this again in the next
anomaly but
there's a trade-off because heavier
particles in some sense have
access more easily to new physics
very very roughly speaking when you do
particle physics experiments it's easy
to go to low energies and find light
particles
it's hard expensive time consuming
technologically challenging
to go to high energies and look at heavy
particles
energy and mass are related because of e
equals m c squared so energy and mass to
a particle physicist
just the same kind of thing so you want
to do experiments that involve
heavy particles because they might
have enough oomph to be directly
connected to physics you haven't
discovered yet on the other hand as we
just said
heavy particles tend to decay into
lighter particles right so if you tried
to make a meson with a top quark for
example
it wouldn't work there's literally not
enough
time to make a particle you can actually
study
out of a top quark and an antiquark of
some other form
so b mesons in some sense are in a sweet
spot
they're in a spot where you have some
access to physics beyond what we've seen
so far
but you have enough time to make these
things look at them
and figure out what their properties
should be compare those properties to
what you actually
see this is so important that there is
literally
an entire experiment at the large hadron
collider
devoted to looking at b mesons in
different ways it's called
cleverly enough l h c b b
for bottom quark okay this particular
experiment you know at any one
experiment you look for many many
different kinds of things the thing that
we're looking for
in the example that is relevant today is
the decay
of a b meson into electrons and muons
i should say electrons or muons a
neutral b
meson so that would be a bottom quark
with let's say an anti-down quark okay
that would be electrically neutral
that can decay into a pair of electrons
that is to say not not two electrons but
an electron and a positron
an electron and an anti-electron so the
net charge remains zero
or the b meson can decay into a muon and
an anti-muon
so we make a prediction we hire our best
theorists right we
set the graduate students to work here
we do feynman diagrams we do
particle physics and we make a
prediction for the rate
at which a certain kind of beam as on
should decay into electrons or into
muons
and it turns out in the standard model
the relevant processes by which such a
decay
can happen treat electrons and muons
basically alike
okay there's enough energy there that
the mass scales are above
the masses of the electrons and the
muons so you should just be able to
decay
into electrons and muons equally that's
the theoretical prediction the ratio
of decays into electrons to the ratio of
decays into muons
should be about one what in fact you see
at the lhcb experiment seems to be
that there's only about 85 percent as
many muons being produced as electrons
eighty-five percent is not a hundred
percent that was the theoretical
prediction
now both the experimental result
and the theoretical prediction have
error bars okay
the theoretical prediction has error
bars because the way that we make
calculations in particle physics
makes a lot of approximations you have
to get those approximations under
control but there's going to be some
slop there okay that leads to an error
bar some uncertainty in the prediction
and of course every experiment in the
world has uncertainty in what it sees
you only collect a finite amount of data
you don't completely understand your
detector all that stuff
but still the difference between 85 and
100
is pretty noticeable in mathematical
terms the way the particle physicists
like to think about it is in terms of
sigma so if you imagine that your
prediction is a gaussian what is the
fancy
term for a bell curve okay then the
number of standard deviations away from
the prediction is the number of sigma
so this particular example of the b
mesons decaying into electrons and muons
has a 3.5 sigma statistical significance
3.5 sigma 3.563.5
standard deviation difference between
the experimental prediction
and the theoretical so the experimental
result and the theoretical prediction
okay you can convert 3.5 sigma
into a confidence level this is to say
99.98
confidence now that doesn't mean that
it's 99.98
chance of being new physics we'll talk
about that later but it gives you a
rough idea that this seems to be a
big difference between the theoretical
prediction and the experimental
outcome 3.5 sigma now
as many of you know particle physicists
are very very persnickety
about what counts as a discovery that
would really get you into the record
books particle physics wise
um the what they made up the standard
that
three sigma is what you call evidence
for
something so we're allowed to say that
the lhcb has found evidence for
a difference between the number of
electrons and muons produced in the
decays of bimesons
you don't get to call it a discovery
until you get five sigma which is much
higher
confidence level so we're at the
discovery the evidence for level
not yet at the discovery level the other
anomaly came a couple weeks later
is again an old one that has been
verified apparently by this new
experiment
and this is g minus 2 of the muon
g minus 2 is a way of characterizing
how strong the muon is as a magnet
the muon is a charged particle and it is
spinning
and when you take electric charge and
you move it
including spinning it you create a
magnetic field this is a result of
maxwell's equations back in the 1800s
okay
so a spinning charged particle like a
muon is a little magnet has a little
magnetic field
and guess what the standard model of
particle physics predicts precisely how
strong of a magnet it is classically
that's not exactly right but roughly
speaking if it weren't for quantum
mechanical corrections
the g which is how we measure the
we relate the amount of magnetic field
to the amount of spin
g would equal two if there were no such
thing as quantum mechanical corrections
there's a
number called g for a muon or for an
electron etc
different ones for every different kind
of particle for the muon
the classical value would be two that's
the ratio roughly speaking
of the magnetic field to the spin of the
particle
and there are quantum corrections in the
world and so you can predict those and
they're very very tiny
so rather than giving the actual value
of g
we give g minus two so we separate out
the classical part which is the two
and we just look at the difference so
the standard model
predicts that for a muon g
should be 2.002331841
plus some extra digits that are lost in
the experimental error okay
2.002331841
so you can see why you would subtract
off the two and then you go out and
measure it
you do the experiment that is done at
fermilab and what you measure
is 2.002331836
you got that so if i subtract off the
two for you
the g minus two prediction is two three
three one eight four one the measurement
is
two three three one eight three six the
difference between the four one and the
three six and the last two digits there
and then there's more digits after that
like i said okay
so that's a difference the magnetic
field of the muon seems to be a tiny
tiny bit smaller
than the standard model would predict
now you don't measure
the magnetic field directly what you
actually measure is
you take a bunch of muons you put them
in a storage ring
okay so it's much like the large hadron
collider or any other particle physics
experiment you have a ring
you put some muons in there and you
accelerate them and guide them with
magnetic fields
and then you try to measure their
properties but as i said muons don't
last forever they decay
so it's hard to do physics with muons
they keep decaying on you
but if you really speed them up very
much right near the speed of light then
they'll last long enough for you to do
interesting physics on them
what you're actually measuring is not
the magnetic field directly but
how the muons decay into electrons the
precise
energy of the electrons they decay into
and the precise angle at which they're
spat out
that depends on the spin and the
magnetic field of the muon in
predictable ways
so what we have is a difference once
again between the prediction of the
standard model and what we've measured
at the straightforward let's just plug
in
and cross our fingers level this is a
4.2
sigma result little more than four
standard deviations between the standard
model prediction and the actual
experimental measurement
that equates to 99.9987 percent
confidence okay that's a lot of
confidence but it's not quite
five sigma yet now as i said
this is a result from fermilab outside
uh chicago where you can go visit
fermilab i don't know
we're still in the middle of a global
pandemic but if you have a chance
visiting fermilab is a fun thing to do
it's a very beautiful
sight and what they've done is
something extraordinarily clever and
impressive
there was a previous measurement like i
said there was a previous version of
this experiment
done at brookhaven national laboratory
which is on long island in new york
okay so brookhaven had this big storage
ring they did this measurement
they got an anomaly they got about a
three sigma difference between the
standard model prediction
and the the and the experimental result
now
the thing is that brookhaven even though
it's a fantastic particle physics
laboratory it just doesn't have the
oomph
that fermilab does it doesn't have the
ability to generate as many muons at the
energies that fermilab does
but it did have this beautiful storage
ring for storing the muons once you made
them right
so people are wondering and this is like
almost 20 years ago people were saying
like
what should we do should we build a new
storage ring at fermilab so we have
better muons or
what what's the alternative to doing
that and they costed it out
it would cost a certain number of
millions of dollars to build a new
storage ring at fermilab
it was about 10 of that price to
literally
pack up the storage ring at brookhaven
put it on a boat
sail the boat around florida up through
the gulf of mexico up through the
mississippi river on a barge
unload the storage ring onto a big
flatbed truck we're talking about
i should have i should have looked this
up but the storage ring is
a couple of tens of meters across right
so
it's on a big truck and it extends
across a three-lane highway that's
roughly how big it is i very much
encourage you to go look up the images
of this journey that the storage ring
took from brookhaven to fermilab
drive it across the state of illinois in
the middle of the night when there's not
a lot of traffic
unload it at fermilab put it together
build a new laboratory around it
that's what they did they actually did
this a few years ago
the journey of the muon g-2 ring from
long island to illinois
is one of the great triumphant stories
in the history of particle physics it's
well worth looking up
okay as i said on twitter once there's a
lot of
hard hat work that goes into modern high
energy
particle physics building things moving
them putting them together
it's really very very impressive and
what we're left with at the end of the
day
is um a little bit of news from europe a
little bit of news from the midwestern
united states
telling us that there are these
experimental results with muons
that are slightly at odds with the
standard model of particle physics
neither one of them
quite yet rises to the level of being
5 sigma in fact i quoted the muon g
minus 2 result as 4.2 sigma
i think it's true this is sometimes hard
to dig out of things but
i think where that comes from is the
brookhaven result
by itself was three point some sigma
and then fermilab with its data by
itself was another three point sum sigma
and they combined them right you're
allowed to do that if you think that
you're both right
um you're allowed to combine them
together to get a 4.2 sigma
deviation to be fair they're using the
same storage ring maybe that's something
to keep in mind
anyway you have these two results both
with muons
what does it mean well it's a difference
between the prediction of the standard
model of particle physics and what
you've observed
therefore if it's true which we'll talk
about in a second it is the sign that
the standard model is not complete
that you need to invoke new physics of
some sort
now as i said in the intro uh nothing's
been upended
it's not overthrowing the standard model
i talked about this a little bit on a
radio program outside chicago and
actually the radio host came up with the
right analogy here
it's adding on a new addition to your
house not demolishing your house and
building another one
okay all of the existing pieces of the
standard
model are a hundred percent in place if
these results are correct if they are
pointing to new physics there are
other particles either bosons or
fermions or some combination
it's kind of tricky right but there are
new particles and fields
that are not part of the standard model
that are gently influencing
the particles that are in the standard
model but the particles that are in the
standard model are still there
nothing has changed about them their
interactions are the same
the underlying philosophy of dealing
with these is still quantum field theory
etc
as a personal note i had to be very very
specific because
i'm on the record as telling people that
the physics
the laws of physics underlying our
everyday lives are completely known
okay are well understood and i know
perfectly well
when i say that out loud that people are
going to misunderstand me
and i know exactly the ways in which
they're going to misunderstand me and i
try
really hard i bend over backwards to be
impossible to be misunderstood and yet
it happens so i got several people
saying so does this mean you were wrong
when you said the laws of physics are
completely well understood
so i was certainly never saying
that the laws of physics are completely
understood
there are obviously physical phenomena
that are not
well understood even within the realm
perfectly speaking just of particle
physics and quantum field theory we
don't understand dark energy we don't
understand the matter antimatter
asymmetry don't understand dark matter
etc okay lots of things we don't
understand
very very high confidence there are new
laws out there to be understood
my point was the stuff that makes up you
and me and the environment around us the
everyday life part of that sentence
that part is understood it is very very
very very probable that we
will discover new physics that we don't
yet understand my argument has always
been
whatever those discoveries are they will
not affect how we think about the
physics of everyday life
what is going on in your body and in the
body of the floor beneath you
etc okay and guess what these new
results even if they're 100
true leave that claim completely fine
completely unaltered because remember
the difference between let's say in the
mu on g minus 2
we're talking about a difference in the
magnetic moment of a muon
between 2.002331841
and 2.002331836
that's not the kind of difference that's
going to make a difference in your
everyday life
especially because you don't have any
muons inside you
muons decay away very very quickly in
both of these cases
what we're finding is incredibly tiny
changes between the predictions of the
standard model
and the experimental results such that
they will have no
impact whatsoever on what is going on
inside you
biologically to see these differences at
work
you need to build a particle accelerator
and you do extraordinarily careful
measurements it's not going to help
explain consciousness or anything like
that okay
had to get off that that off my chest
thanks for indulging me there okay
if you're the kind of person who has to
fill out expense forms
and you're also the kind of person who
would rather be doing real work
than paperwork expensify is for you
expensify is the most widely used
expense management platform
in the world with over 10 million users
and expensify makes it easy for
you to get paid back expensify makes it
easy to manage
your expenses your bills invoices travel
and your business card spending all in
one place so you can focus your time on
what's important
you don't have to worry about losing
receipts with expensify
you can just take a picture and toss it
if you have to travel for work these
days
lots of supported features for the
modern day traveler such as
automatic international currency
conversion concierge for your travel
needs
real-time notifications and mileage
tracking
you can get paid back as soon as the
next day so visit expensify.com
mindscape to get started with a free
trial that's expensify.com
mindscape let's go let's be more serious
what could be going on what is going on
when we say new physics that can cover a
lot of ground what kind of new physics
are we talking about here okay
well again the answer is actually pretty
straightforward it doesn't require great
new leaps of faith this is these are
results that
would be fairly straightforward to
explain
uh you have to be careful that when you
explain it you don't introduce
new anomalies elsewhere but these are
results that are the bread and butter of
particle physics trying to explain
so here's the basic story you've heard
of findman diagrams okay this is richard
feynman's
great calculational tool a fineman
diagram is a way of thinking about
how processes of interacting particles
happen
as described by quantum field theory so
a feynman diagram has a bunch of
particles coming in
indicated by lines straight lines or
wiggly lines or dashed lines or whatever
then they interact with each other they
trade other particles back and forth
okay in some complicated way or some
simple way
then they go off in a new set of
particles leaving
so they're incoming particles they're
interactions
and the particle lines that are entirely
inside the diagram that is to say
neither coming from
the beginning nor going out to the end
neither incoming or outgoing particles
though inside particles
are called virtual particles so we say
there are incoming particles they
exchange virtual particles and they
convert into the outgoing particles
and these finement diagrams these
cartoons that we draw
they not only represent what can happen
they also are calculational tools every
single
cartoon findmen diagram you draw
represents a number
there's an algorithm for converting each
diagram into a number
and that number is the contribution of
that diagram
to the quantum mechanical amplitude
corresponding to that process
so if you let's say have two electrons
coming together and they scatter off
each other
what's happening well you draw two lines
for two electrons
electrons coupled to photons for example
so you would draw a diagram where two
electrons come in
they exchange a photon a little wiggly
line a virtual photon and then the two
electrons go off
okay so you have a way of converting
that diagram
into a number that's a contribution to
the
amplitude for two electrons to scatter
into two electrons
there's another contribution coming from
a diagram where you draw the two
electrons come in
they exchange a virtual photon and then
they exchange another virtual photon
and then they scatter off okay so two
photon exchange
and guess what you can exchange three
photons or four photons etc
every different diagram you draw makes a
contribution to that final answer
then you can draw diagrams that for
example have an elect
two electrons come in a photon leaves
one
but rather than just being absorbed by
the other one
this photon splits into an electron
positron pair
which hangs out for a little while and
then gets reconverted into a photon
and that photon gets absorbed by the
other electron
so that has a contribution that you need
to include
there are an infinite number of finemen
diagrams containing all the different
particles of the standard model for any
process
that you want to imagine in principle
this doesn't seem very helpful by itself
how can i calculate an
infinite number of diagrams well the
answer is
every as the diagrams get more
complicated
their contributions get smaller at least
when
nature is being nice to us this is what
is called the perturbative regime
in particle physics the strong nuclear
force is not perturbative and therefore
it's a harder kind of messy thing as
we'll talk about in a second but for
things like electromagnetism
or the weak force or exchanging higgs
bosons
all of these are perturbative they have
the property
that the more complicated the feynman
diagram is the
tinier its contribution is to the
ultimate answer
what that means is if you look at just
the simplest findment diagrams you get a
good approximation
to the specific process that you're
looking at and that's why as i
alluded to before your theoretical
prediction comes with error bars
it is not a precise prediction it is an
approximation because you're ignoring
the very complicated findment diagrams
when you're doing work like this when
you're doing these particular kinds of
experiments where
very very high precision counts you
still got to include
quite a number of very very complicated
looking finding diagrams and there's a
lot of computational
numerical work that goes into this but
still you can not only calculate
an answer which should be approximately
right you can predict approximately how
right it is
you have an idea of what the errors are
because you can approximate
the even more complicated finding
diagrams that you're not
actually computing okay so the theory
gives you not only a prediction
but error bars on what the prediction is
so that's very nice okay
that's the kind of theory work that goes
into
predicting either the rate at which a
bemezon decays into electrons or muons
or the magnetic moment of the muon which
is measured in the muon g minus two
experiment okay
the magnetic moment now why does that
matter all these feynman diagrams well
because the magnetic moment is
essentially
an interaction between the particle and
an
external magnetic field the magnetic
field that is literally in the magnets
in the ring right but to a particle
physicist a magnetic field is just a
bunch of photons
so you can think of the interaction
between the muon
and the magnetic field it's in as an
interaction between
a photon and the muon and there will be
many such
interactions one is direct that's the
two
and g minus two that's the two you're
subtracting off the photon just hits the
muon okay
and it has a little magnetic field but
then that mu1 can also
spit off a photon which converts into an
electron positron pair
and maybe either the electron or the
positron couples to the external
magnetic field
so the way to think about it is what you
think of ordinarily is just a single
particle a single line moving through
empty space all by itself
quantum mechanics tells us that in fact
this particle is being renormalized
what does that mean that means that
there are quantum
processes which you can think of in
feynman diagram language
as particles being spit out and
reabsorbed
by that muon all the time so what you
should really think of is a little cloud
around the muon of these virtual
particles so these virtual photons and
electrons and heavier things
all of them contribute to the way in
which the muon interacts with the
magnetic field around it
it's not just the magnetic field is
feeling a little tiny point particle
called the muon
the magnetic field is affecting a little
cloud of all the particles in the
standard model of particle physics with
different
contributions which the standard model
lets you predict
okay so that's all of the contributions
to
the g minus two other than the two these
are all the virtual particles and in
fact the
first contribution to the g minus two
uh was worked out by julian schwinger
the first contribution beyond the two
julian schwinger uh sort of a
contemporary and rival
of richard feynman one of the other
people who won the nobel prize for
showing how to renormalize quantum
electrodynamics
schwinger was the first to calculate the
quantum corrections
to the magnetic moment and he was so
impressed by
his own calculation the result that he
got is engraved on his tombstone
okay so this is an important thing i
think he was calculating the magnetic
moment the anomalous magnetic moment as
we call it of the electron
but once you get the electron you can do
it for the muon just as well
okay so that's what exists in
the standard model and the story for the
decay of the b
mesons is well the b meson is going to
spit out some particle you know a w
boson or a z
boson which will then decay into the
electrons or to the muons and you can
calculate that too it's the same kind of
thing you do a bunch of finemen diagrams
the more complicated ones are tinier
you add them up you get the answer okay
so
if you find that you do that you've
added up all these finding diagrams
you've gotten the answer in the standard
model of particle physics you make your
prediction and it disagrees
with the experimental result what's
going on
it is not that hard to imagine there's
another particle
that you didn't know about because it's
not in the standard model of particle
physics
and maybe it interacts directly with
muons or maybe it interacts
indirectly because it interacts you know
with w bosons or with gluons even or
something like that this is the game you
start to play
once you've been told there's this
particular disagreement
between the standard model prediction
and what you actually see in the
experiment you can say well
if i invent a new quantum field
representing a new kind of particle
and i give it different interactions
with muons and electrons and neutrinos
in the whole shebang
then i can plug that new theory into the
finemen diagram machinery
make a new prediction and explain this
anomaly
and what we're not going to go into here
are all the different possibilities okay
that's what you mean by these
possibilities the possibilities that
particle physicists are considering
are what are the new particles we could
introduce into this game
that would reproduce correctly the
experimental results
from lhcb and from the mu1 g-2
experiment but nevertheless there are
some general principles that we can
mention let me let me mention one very
very important
general principle which is that as the
new particle you're inventing
becomes heavier and heavier so one of
the features of the new particle you're
inventing will be it has a mass
right it's not massless or otherwise
would have seen it a long time ago
mass less or low mass particles are easy
to make
heavy particles are hard to make e
equals m c squared so you need more
energy to make a hefty particle
what you're imagining here because we
haven't seen these particles directly
right so we've done experiments like at
the large hadron collider we made the
higgs boson by smashing protons together
and
seeing the decay products that would be
representative of the higgs boson
decaying we declared victory nobel
prizes
champagne bottles the whole shebang okay
even earlier than that at what was
called lep the large electron positron
collider
we made a whole bunch of z-bosons and we
let them decay and we saw
everything that came out of the decay of
the z-boson and roughly speaking
that's the best limit that we have on
new physics
up to a certain mass scale because if
the particle is
lighter than the z boson the z boson
should have decayed into it
and that would have affected the
probability of the z decaying and
therefore its lifetime okay and we
didn't see anything
so we have pretty good evidence that any
particles that are
lighter than the z boson or lighter than
half the z boson if you want to decay
into a particle in an
antiparticle pair any particles lighter
than the z
boson either don't exist or they are so
very very weakly coupled
to the z-boson that they just didn't
ever get produced
so for example axions or hypothetical
particles that would be much lighter
than a z-boson
but just don't decouple to the z boson
and therefore they're just not produced
in the whip
in order for these particles then these
hypothetical particles that we're
inventing to explain our muon anomalies
uh in order for them to be relevant they
need to couple
to muons obviously and you know muons
couple z-bosons
so we expect that if you couple the
muons a couple of z-bosons and therefore
you already
have a lower limit on what the mass of
this new particle can be
so between the fact that the z boson
didn't decay into it
and the fact that we didn't haven't yet
seen it directly at the large hadron
collider
we know that any new particles you're
going to invent are going to be fairly
heavy
but they can't be too heavy uh that's
another feature of findman diagrams
what you're imagining is that you have
these virtual particles these virtual
quantum contributions to what you're
actually measuring
and one of the things that is part of
the rulebook of feynman diagrams
is the more massive a particle is
the less important its virtual particles
are
to whatever thing you're looking at in
the limit
as a new particle becomes heavier and
heavier and heavier
its contribution to feynman diagrams in
the form of virtual particles
gets less and less goes to zero okay
so on the one hand we have a lower limit
on how massive these particles can be
on the other hand there's kind of an
upper limit not a very hard and fast
upper limit but they can't be too heavy
otherwise they wouldn't have any effect
at all so in both cases
very very roughly speaking the energy
scales for these new particles
have to be at approximately large hadron
collider energies
hundreds of times the mass of the proton
okay the higgs boson is is
i think around 125 billion electron
volts
that's the that's the unit people use
the proton is roughly 1 billion electron
volt so
in my brain because i'm not very precise
about these things i convert
mass of proton to billion electron volts
gev
giga electron volts okay billion
electron volts so the higgs is about 125
gev the top quark is about 174
gev those are the heaviest particles
we've ever made
in order to explain uh these particular
kinds of anomalies
we we're talking about particles with
hundreds
or maybe thousands of gev
and that's enough to give a little tiny
nudge
to the predicted effects in the muons
that we're measuring and
maybe enough to actually make it at the
lhc
okay that's the hopeful thing and i
should say to be perfectly fair to give
credit here
a lot of the um specific numbers that
i'm quoting to you i got from the
resonances
blog resonances is a blog that you
should follow if you're a fan of real
particle physics adam felkowski
aka jester on online uh is a working
particle physicist who follows these
anomalies and tells you what to think
about them
in great detail so that's where i'm
getting these particular numbers from
but you could have guessed i mean
honestly i'm trying to be
accurate because there's always sneaky
things in particle physics that you you
might miss
but your guess would have been that that
was about the right energy scale
for new physics to be there because if
it were lighter than that we would have
seen it
if it were heavier than that we wouldn't
be able to see it the current state of
the art
for looking for new kinds of physics is
hundreds or thousands
hundreds or thousands of billion
electron volts that's where these new
particles
might be okay so that's what the kind of
thing we're going to want now
there are many different candidates for
making this
right grand unification gives us new
particles
supersymmetry gives us new particles
extra dimensional models
either large extra dimensions or warped
extra dimensions
there's many many different kinds of
specific models that's exactly what i'm
not going to be talking about in any
detail because i don't know
which one is right and i'm pretty sure
no one knows what is right there were
literally
50 papers that appeared on the archive
the day after
the muon g minus 2 result came out
because everyone had their favorite
model ready to go they knew the
experiment would be
telling us its results they plugged in
the numbers and submitted their paper
okay
there's a lot of different possibilities
out there uh
i did want to say just a couple of
things about why
the specific experiments are so good why
muons right
is it should we be thinking
that because both the lhcb result and
the fermion muon g minus 2
fermion fermilab muon g minus 2 result
came from muons does that indicate that
there's something special about muons
uh no it doesn't it doesn't either
directly or even
you know maybe um it's always possible
but it would be a coincidence you know
the energy scales implied by these two
different
uh results are slightly different from
each other so there's no sort of plug
and play
single particle that explains both of
them at once
uh maybe you can be clever again you
know it's always hard when the theories
haven't settled down yet
to make statements about no one will
come up with a theory that does this
because
particle physicists are very clever at
coming up with theories that do things
so maybe there's a single particle that
explains both but more likely than not
you're going to need two different kinds
of particles the point of the muons is
just that they're a good place to look
it's looking under the lamp post okay
muons are about 200 times heavier than
electrons which
makes them more sensitive to new physics
muons couple more strongly to the higgs
boson
for example and more than that they just
have a little bit more oomph
to make virtual particles and to be
affected by them
like i said they're unstable but they
live long enough
to put them in a storage ring and search
for the different effects
in the case of the lhcb decays you're
literally comparing
the electrons as a decay product to
something else
so you want to compare into something
that are electron-like
but not too much heavier the muon is
just the perfect thing to look at
so it's probably just a fact that the
muons are a good tool for looking for
new physics
rather than we're learning something
specific about muons okay
that's one point i wanted to make the
other point i wanted to make is
is it right should we believe these
results
right you know what what confidence
should we have
that these results are actually giving
us new physics
so let's talk a little bit about the
sigmas right
the actual confidence intervals were
being quoted here
three point something four point
something sigma so more than a discovery
sorry more than evidence for less than
discovery
uh what should you think when you were
told by particle physicists
that they have a 3.5 sigma result for
example just to pick a number
so 3.5 sigma converts into a 1 in 5 000
chance and sometimes people will say
kind of casually
there's a 1 in 5 000 chance of seeing
this result
if it weren't new physics right and what
they're trying to tell you is it's
probably new physics
um but that's clearly wrong and you know
most almost everyone knows this i'm just
making explicit what everyone knows i'm
not saying anything especially profound
the fact that something is a 3.5 sigma
deviation
between prediction and observation
does not mean there's only one in 5 000
chance
that um it's new physics what it means
is
there is only a one in five thousand
chance that it would be
a statistical fluctuation if
you got both your theory and your
experiment correct
okay so in other words like we said your
theory
has error bars your theory is not making
a perfect prediction there are some
error bars in your theoretical
uh confidence that you're making the
right prediction and the experiment
every experiment has
error bars also has anyone who has done
a you know physics lab
in college can attest okay
so the correct thing to say is that
there's a one in five thousand chance of
a 3.5 sigma result
being a statistical fluctuation if you
have exactly correctly characterized
the error bars on both your theory and
your experiment
now particle physicists have made up
these thresholds so like i said
three sigma is evidence for five sigma's
discovery
that's completely made up okay the
reality is
three sigma results happen all the time
and in fact five sigma results happen
pretty
convincingly and then go away pretty
pretty uh commonly i should say and then
go away
because we don't understand the theory
or the experiment exactly all the time
so the question is you know once you
have a four sigma result even if it's
not technically what particle physicists
have invented as the threshold to call
it a discovery
it's really unlikely to be a statistical
fluctuation
the reason why you know you might say
look once i'm at one in one thousand i
think it's pretty unlikely to be a
statistical fluctuation
that's probably not right because you're
looking at many many different effects
right the point is you can do a thousand
different measurements of a thousand
different quantities in particle physics
no problem
and if you really did understand both
your theory and your experiment you'd
still
expect to see at least one one in a
thousand chance
right there's a an effect you have to be
very careful about you know
let's say you're looking for the higgs
boson and you don't know what the mass
is
we know what it is now but before we
found it we didn't know so
you're separately asking yourself the
question have i seen the higgs boson
at 110 gev have i seen it at 111 gev
have i seen it at 112 gev
all the different possible measurement
outcomes you could get
and so if you're doing a lot of
measurements the chances of getting a
statistical fluctuation go up that is
one
effect to keep in mind the much bigger
thing to worry about is that you've
goofed
either on the theory side or the
experiment side
so let's think about that for the lhc
where they made the b
mesons and they decayed slightly less
often into muons than we predicted
could we be making up could be making a
mistake either theoretically or
experimentally
theoretically we're on solid ground for
this particular experiment and the most
the biggest reason why there's sort of a
natural explanation for that
what you're predicting is the ratio of
the percentage of time the
b meson decays into muons versus
decaying into electrons
if you make either one of those
predictions the rate at which it decays
into electrons
or the rate of which decays into muons
it's easy to make mistakes
because there's a lot going on in these
finemen diagrams there are processes you
don't completely understand
you might have some mistakes in there
but we think we have good experiment
theoretical reason to think you should
be making the same mistakes
in both cases so if for example
uh let's say there's a contribution of i
don't know
the top quark to the rate of this
particular decay
okay and maybe that's hard to predict
because it's hard to make top quarks
hard to study them etc
fine but it should be whatever it is the
same
uncertainty in your prediction for the
muon decays and the electron decays
so our theory predictions for
the decay rates of the b mesons are
under pretty good control we think
however the experiment is very hard to
do okay
the experiment is actually measuring as
we might guess the number of electrons
that are produced and the number of
muons that are produced
the ways in which you detect electrons
and muons are different
and you have and this is where it gets
into the nitty-gritty of doing
experiments there are detector
efficiencies
you know you're not going to see every
electron or every muon being made
so you have to model what those
efficiencies are
and they're going to be a little bit
different for muons and for
electrons if only because there are
holes
in your detector right i mean there's a
beam pipe where the beam comes in
before things smash together and you
make new particles
you don't have uh two pi steradians
coverage
in your detector and there's other more
subtle things going on but the point is
you need to do a little experimental
artistry
to exactly characterize what you expect
in terms of the number of electrons and
the number of muons
and obviously there are thousands of
people working on this they've worked
very hard they're the best in the world
at what they do
we have every reason to believe that
what they have done is as good as can be
done
it doesn't mean it's right right it's
still possible to make mistakes
the good news is there is another
experiment uh called the bell
two experiment b-e-l-l-e in japan
which should be doing the same kind of
experiment in a few years from now
so we'll be checking it okay so there is
an anomaly it's checkable
wait a few years we'll see what happens
that's the story for the b decays
what about for the muon's magnetic
moment the g minus two
well you know we did do the experiment
twice we did a brookhaven we did it at
fermilab
but it uses the same storage ring
that shouldn't be a problem like that's
not really where your error bars
come from there is again going to be a
follow-up experiment there is an
experiment at
j park again in japan just like bell is
which will be separately using a
completely different method
measuring g minus 2 for the muon so that
should give us
some very honest um check on the
fermilab
results but you know we think once again
that in this case we actually have the
experimental
facility pretty well figured out we're
not trying to distinguish between
electrons and muons we're just measuring
the properties of the electrons
where the muons create them we have to
very very well understand the magnetic
field that the muons are in but we think
that's doable so it's a
very very very slight discrepancy
between theory and experiment but we
think
that the experiment is under control the
theory
in the case of the mu on g minus two is
much harder
because you're not comparing muons to
electrons you're just trying to directly
calculate
the property of muons okay so
what are you trying to calculate you're
doing all these feynman diagram
calculations the muon spits off virtual
particles they can spit off more virtual
particles
you have to go for like five different
spittings off and reabsorptions
before you get to the level of accuracy
you need to compare with the data
that's very hard to do and it's not just
that it's work
i already alluded earlier to the fact
that this whole feynman diagram
story doesn't really work very naturally
with the strong interactions with
quantum chromodynamics the strong
nuclear force
for the strong nuclear force simple
diagrams are not necessarily more
important than complicated diagrams you
can't just do the first
few simple ones and then stop so you
might say well then it says hopeless
right like how are we even calculating
this
at all it turns out there are two
different things you can do
okay what you need to do is understand
how these strongly interacting particles
quarks
and gluons how they indirectly interact
with muons
so what you can do is just measure that
separately
so separately from measuring the muon's
magnetic moment
you can do other experiments at the lhc
and formula
and elsewhere which give you
phenomenological data
as we say so data directly from the
experiment
about what the coupling is between muons
and strongly interacting particles in
different regimes
okay so then rather than calculating a
bunch of feynman diagrams you can just
measure the relative contributions of
these strongly interacting particles
to what it is you're trying to figure
out that's a thing you can do
and that is what was done that is where
we got the result
of the standard model prediction which
is off by four sigma
from what fermilab actually measured but
there's another way
to do it there's another way to figure
out what the contributions are from the
strong interactions
which is to try to calculate them
directly so not use experimental data to
try to calculate them but rather than
using feynman diagrams
using what is called lattice quantum
chromodynamics
so basically a lattice is just a big
computer simulation
where you sort of put all of the gluons
and the quarks
onto this computer and you say all right
tell me like just do all these
non-perturbative calculations
uh tell me what the answer is tell me
how strongly
these strongly interacting particles
affect the properties
of the muons and that has been done also
this is an ongoing project and
here's the punch line i really should
have led with this but many of you
already know it
a result was released or was actually
published it was released earlier but it
was published
the same day that fermilab's
muon g minus 2 result came out and these
lattice calculations claim that the
theory fits the data
fine that there isn't really any
discrepancy or more more
more like there's less than a two sigma
discrepancy
between the theoretical predictions and
the experimental result
in other words these lattice people are
claiming
that with their technique of making the
standard model prediction
there's nothing to be explained it fits
the measurement that fermilab has come
up with
now the theorists at fermilab and
elsewhere who made the prediction that
didn't agree
they know that you know we all talk to
each other in particle physics we all
publish papers we read each other's
papers we go to the same conferences
okay
um there these are two different methods
for calculating the same result
and they don't quite agree i mean
they're sort of two sigma away from each
other
and then the lattice thing is another
two sigma away from the experiment so
there's four sigma total
and you i mean that's very very rough
don't quote me on that but that's the
basic idea
um so the people at fermilab and in that
experiment thought about it and they
said look we can't
on this time scale verify the
experiments
the claims that are being made they're
not experiments the theoretical claims
computational results
of the lattice simulations so we're not
going to include it we we can
check and verify and try to understand
these phenomenological measurements that
we have under control so that's what
we're going to go with
so of course future work is required
right so that's you know it's always the
end of these ambiguous stories
not only do we need future work in the
form of better experiments
but we need to figure out this
theoretical disagreement between
different ways
of including the contributions of
strongly interacting particles to the
magnetic moment of the muon
two different ways give you different
results
maybe one of them is right maybe both of
them are right no they can't both be
right there they're
in disagreement maybe they're both wrong
that's always possible
but it's answerable is the point this is
a theoretical calculation you don't need
to build
a bigger particle accelerator to do it
you might need to build a bigger
computer
to get more accurate lattice qcd by the
way lattice qcd is very hard lattice
quantum chromodynamics it's an ex
you know notoriously difficult thing to
do so even though it agrees with the
experiment
we shouldn't jump right to saying well
that one's probably right
we should just be honest and sort of
suspend our judgment
maybe there's a real anomaly here maybe
it's not the theorist will try to get it
right
and it's important to try to get it
right because
even if at the end of the day you say
well i do have an anomaly here
it's just one number it's the magnetic
moment of the muon
there are a number of different
particle physics scenarios that could
ultimately account for it
and therefore it's enormously strong
motivation to build
the next generation of colliders i mean
before you even do that i should of
course say this goes without saying it's
enormous motivation just to keep
looking for things at the large hadron
collider the lhc found the higgs boson
but they didn't turn it off it's still
going
still supposed to be going for years
into the future and so
when you give the experimenters a target
to look for that helps them in their
searches
so it's completely possible that over
the next let's say five years
the large hadron collider discovers new
particles directly
that were not in the standard model of
particle physics
many of us myself included hoped and
expected that that would have happened
by now
and sort of it's it's been frustrating
that it hasn't but that doesn't mean it
won't happen
um the low-hanging fruit has been picked
you know the lhc looked in the obvious
places
but now all right there's higher up
there on the tree there could be more
fruit up there it's still worth looking
for that and if we have a target to
shoot for
it becomes much more motivated but still
there's also a scenario in which the lhc
goes for another five or ten years and
doesn't find anything
then it gives very very strong
motivation for building an
even more powerful particle physics
experiment you know in a sense i can't
help but say
it makes us even more heartbroken that
we didn't build the superconducting
super collider here in the united states
you know in the 1990s before the large
hadron collider got off the ground
the u.s had this plan they even started
they started building the tunnel
underneath waxahachie texas to build a
superconducting supercollider
and the ssc as it was called would have
been finished before the lhc
and it would have been higher energy
noticeably higher energy
so these questions were asking about
could the lhc someday see another
particle that is being hinted at by
these
new anomalies well if the lhc
will eventually be able to find it the
ssc would have found it by now
but we decided collectively through our
decision-making process as a nation that
it wasn't worth the money to us here in
the united states
here now the united states is no longer
in the running for building the next
generation high energy particle physics
accelerator we're not trying
we're not putting forward plausible
plans to do it
these things are so expensive you need
multinational
cooperation to do it the united states
infamously is not very good at
multinational
cooperation and we just don't have the
national gumption right now to do it by
ourselves so
it might happen in europe it might
happen in asia in china or japan or
somewhere else
hopefully it happens because i do think
that discovering new particles
is important um so let's end on that
note because i think that is an
optimistic place to end
discovering new particles is important
why
not because of the particles you know
you've discovered another particle big
whoop
in some sense okay you have a lot of
particles already what are you going to
do with the new one well the point is
that the new particle implies new ideas
it implies new physics as we like to say
it's not going to help us build better
smartphones or vaccines for the next
global pandemic
it helps us better understand the laws
of nature what we're hoping for
is not just one more particle to add to
the zoo
what we're hoping is that that particle
gives us evidence for some new
principles
right whether that principle is there
are extra dimensions of space or there
is supersymmetry or there's grand
unification
or there are new laws new forces that
might be related to dark matter somehow
there's many different possibilities
right new dynamics who knows
but that's what's exciting not finding a
new particle it's finding new
kinds of physics entirely will that
necessarily happen if these anomalies
turn out to be true well i don't know
we don't know can't say that but if we
don't
follow them up then we don't find these
things that we can say
right and it is a feature of particle
physics that
you can do these clever experiments like
the muon g minus two
and find new phenomena the magnetic
moment of the muon is a little bit
different
but you can't study them in detail you
got that one number
it's very very hard to go beyond that to
do detailed experimentation
of what is out there what properties it
has how the new particles and fields
interact with each other
you need to build a giant particle
accelerator that can reach really really
high energies that's the only way we
know how to do it
um so i'm hopeful like look you know i
try to be level-headed about this
i was disappointed when the lhc didn't
find anything right away
and so it's easy to become a little bit
jaded and cynical saying ah this is just
an anomaly it'll go away like all the
other anomalies
and maybe that's true but maybe not
we're allowed to be a little bit
hopeful to say you know maybe this is it
maybe this is the time that we go beyond
the standard model
the first truly new surprising result
that was completely unexpected
in a particle physics experiment since
the 1970s a particle of physics
experiment here on earth you know we had
neutrino
masses and things like that but those
were kind of a little bit expected also
so
this is this is something different if
it's true
maybe it's true maybe it's not that kind
of epistemic uncertainty
that's where we got to live that's where
the excitement comes enjoy it
revel in it let's see what happens next
[Music]
you